let me talk to you about your beautiful
film wander darkly
uh i don't even want to try to sum up
this movie because it's about so much
it's a very intense but beautiful movie
about this couple
and um and there's a lot of twists and
turns
and it's done very beautifully there's
some intense
scenes and there's a scene where and i
don't think i'm giving anything away
here because it
it could be a dream it could not be a
dream but there's a scene where
your character is put into a morgue
drawer and just seeing you just because
i know you and i know you're an actor
and you're acting in a role
but you get slid into one of those real
morgue drawers and it looked real and it
was very
haunting it felt real and uh it was
real it's a little independent movie
it's not that they built the place for
me
you know we went into a place and uh
that's a real morgue yeah i mean i'm
sure they
i mean they took whoever lives there
out before i went in but uh but yeah i
went into the real thing and it was my
first day of shooting
i thought they were like trying to to
send me a message you know he was like
oh welcome
we love to have you sit down here
lay down and then when they close that
thing man
the sound of that i mean i hope the next
time i hear it i'm dead because
it's a it's horrible it's horrendous
it's like
and then is it lit in there like what is
it
lit in there can you see when they close
a mortgage
why would you put light in there okay
that's all right you're right that's a
stupid question
the dead person might want some good
lighting that's all they're in the
drawer
exactly it's saving saving light you
know like saving energy light obviously
oh my god that must have been a dramatic
experience
it was horrible and the and then there
was a scene happening out there so they
kept me there while the scene was going
and then i could hear god and then time
passed it felt like an eternity to me it
was a probably 10 15 seconds till
someone remembered oh
open it and they got me out and i was
like white and going like
oh it was it was intense it was it was
just
uh i mean
a great a reminder of what an actor
has to be ready for you know yeah i
would think so
i would think so and also you're very
lucky they remembered what if they just
said
let's go you know it's time to eat and
they all left i mean you were lucky
i'm lucky then now that you say that it
was the first day of shooting and not
the last year
you could still be there now yeah
exactly uh let me ask you you're you
have very
uh your co-star in this film is sienna
miller
very beautiful very talented cnn miller
you two have a very good
um chemistry together you perform very
well together
uh does it help that you're friends in
real life you've known each other for a
long time
yeah definitely there was like a
chemistry that you we lend to the
characters yeah
you can't rehearse that i mean it takes
years to get that right
and uh and we were trying to work
together for quite a long time
and the script arrived and it was a
fantastic opportunity because it's a
through the force i mean what she does
is
incredible uh yeah i urge people to
watch it because
she's fantastic in the film and uh but
it's a really tough
i mean job you know for for for an actor
and it was
beautiful to live the experience with
someone i admire i care and i like
well you and i have been friends now for
i want to say at least
five years so i think it's inevitable
that we will be in a film together
we have such great chemistry i i i i
can't wait for that uh i can't wait for
that
no really i am honest i am honest
good i don't know what you have to do in
spanish because i know your spanish is
really good
[Laughter]
you have to build a new audience since
now you don't have an audience there
i'm going to start an american market
yes i'm going to start i'm going to just
oh my show now i'm just going to only
work i'm going to try and just win over
mexico and work very hard to win over
the people of mexico
you know forget america it's time just
for me to focus on mexico
and and the good thing is you can stay
in america because there's more than 30
million people there from mexico zoo
trust me i said i see them all the time
i live in los angeles
you know they're they're holding the
whole state together
well listen this is an absolute delight
to see you make sure i mention
wander darkly it's a beautiful film is
now on demand on
apple tv prime video or wherever
you get your movies uh diego i
salute you yet again trust me i don't
even think it's noon here yet
but salud
thank you very much uh it's it's a a
pleasure always to be in your show
police navidad feliz ano
a good mezcal because tomorrow you might
be having some headache
yeah i'm gonna i have the headache now
this
[Laughter]
with your big head that must be
[Laughter]
with my big head a headache is fatal